Traductor: Adelina Bordea
Revisor: Silvina Katz
(Música)
Muchas gracias.
El tema este de tener que
mantener el equilibrio
mientras intento hacer cosas con el pedal,
con los nervios, no lo llevo muy bien.
Así que, si me caigo, incorporo
algo de humor en el momento TEDx.
Como habréis notado,
en esta canción he hecho algo de trampa.
A mis pies tengo
a una de mis mejores amigas.
La llamo mi "magic box" porque
me permite hacer magia en vivo
de una manera un poco más real.
Hace varios años, veía que
músicos con los que colaboraba
llenaban esos huecos musicales
que había dentro de mi cabeza
y cuando los quitaba, me sentía vacía.
Sentía que no estaba haciendo
lo suficiente en el escenario.
Sabía que había posibilidades,
pero no tenía la manera de hacerlas.
No tenía a tres coristas
detrás cantando conmigo.
No tenía a un batería guiñándome.
Entonces invertí algo de tiempo
e intenté averiguar cómo poder hacer
que una canción se construyera
en vivo rápidamente.
Para aquellos de vosotros que no entendáis
cómo funciona: es muy simple.
Simplemente, pulso un botón.
(Música)
Pulso un botón.
Al pulsar el botón, empieza a grabarse
y entonces puedo hacer...
Y, al pulsar el botón de nuevo,
Se va repitiendo lo que acabo de grabar.
se graba algo por encima.
Y, al pulsar el botón de nuevo...
Es muy simple.
(Música)
Cuando me pidieron hacer este evento,
me pidieron también
componer algo animado y feliz,
que es algo que se me da bastante mal.
Tengo tendencia
a las canciones melancólicas.
Esta canción, sin querer,
la compuse muy rápidamente.
Y espero que os guste.
(Música)